et on commence cette page cinéma avec
vous c'est ninja alors comme tous les
mercredis on fait le point sur les
sorties ciné de cette semaine le premier
film que vous nous proposez ce soir
c'est le nouveau Creed et oui Mathilde
c'est le troisième volet de la saga
Creed issue de la franchise des Rocky
créent à l'époque par le grand Sylvester
Stallone dans ce nouvel opus on retrouve
Michael Bill Jordan devant et derrière
la caméra cette fois-ci c'est le passé
qui s'invite dans la vie du protagoniste
qui l'incarne à Denise Creed regardez
Damien était comme mon frère
[Musique]
on peut même plus parler faut peut-être
que ça se joue sur le riz
en ce moment-là
alors ce frère de cœur dont parle Adonis
c'est Damien alors qu'a donné c'est
désormais devenu un père de famille
comblé retraité des rings mais
promoteurs de match cet ami d'enfance
pas très recommandable mais prodige de
la boxe refait surface Damien lui a tout
appris à l'époque et se retrouve libéré
de prison après plusieurs années si au
début les retrouvailles semblent bien se
passer les tensions ne tardent pas à
arriver ça me donne envie d'aller le
voir en tout cas Céline on continue avec
un tout autre genre vous allez nous
parler d'Empire of light alors tout à
fait Mathilde on parle beaucoup de films
sur le cinéma en ce moment après
Babylone en janvier dernier the Fabel
Mans la semaine dernière c'est
maintenant sam Mendes le réalisateur de
1917 et Skyfall qui s'attaque maintenant
à ce sujet dans Empire of light le film
raconte la vie d'un ancien cinéma dans
une station balnéaire du sud de
l'Angleterre et surtout il parle de
l'histoire d'amour entre Hillary la
responsable du cinéma qui tente de
préserver sa santé mentale fragile et
Stéphane le petit nouveau de l'équipe
Empire of light à bord de des pro
pratique comme la santé mentale le
racisme ou la crise des cinémas le
réalisateur c'est notamment inspiré de
sa propre enfance et pour terminer
Céline vous nous proposer une comédie
française tout à fait il s'agit du film
Les petites victoires de Mélanie au
frais on y retrouve Jules à Piaton dans
le rôle d'Alice une mairesse et
maîtresse d'école d'un petit village de
400 habitants en Bretagne à lui souhaite
le sauver de la désertification dans son
combat elle croise Émile interprété par
Michel Blanc un sexagénaire au caractère
bien trempé qui souhaite apprendre à
lire regarder qu'est-ce que vous faites
là
pourquoi tu sais pas lire c'est jamais
rentré dans ma tête et puis après j'ai
oublié
a eu
ça
et toi tu es moche comme ton père
c'est un feel good movie qui aborde avec
tendresse et humour les enjeux des
petites communes de France ça a l'air de
en tout cas comme d'habitude petit tour
de plateau est-ce que il y a un film que
vous avez préféré parmi la sélection
régime moi je serais bien m'intéressée
par empailleur of lights et vous Julien
pas trop de d'avis moi je pense que
j'irai voir Creed au cinéma moi j'irai
voir les petites victoires comme ça
chacun son film